thank you
[Music]
hello and good evening it is seven
o'clock this is a Sky News special
program where we'll be asking can we
trust the police we'll be answering your
questions
the future of the Metropolitan Police
and forces across the country in the
spotlight again after a damning report
into police standards what we have found
right across the net is institutional
and systemic racism sexism and
homophobia
the Metropolitan Police Commissioner
rejects that charge but vows to take
action to protect the public
I'm doing everything possible to remove
to spot anybody and remove them who
proposes any risk to the public
but over 20 years since structural
failures were identified in the police
after the death of Stephen Lawrence we
hear from the victims who are still
being let down
well we'll get into your questions and
concerns about the police in a moment
but first let's take a closer look at
the main points from Dame Louise Casey's
review well it found that the force the
Metropolitan Police is institutionally
racist misogynistic and homophobic it
says a lack of vigilance towards
officers abusing their positions has
allowed for predatory behavior to
flourish
12 percent of women in the Mets said
they experience sexual harassment or
assault and rape cases have been dropped
after key evidence was destroyed when
overstuffed fridges and freezes broke
well most of the findings have been
accepted by the Metropolitan Police
Commissioner Sir Mark rally with one
important exception he still insists
that the problems within the force can't
be defined as institutional
we accept that I accept the findings of
the reports absolutely
the full findings of the report
I'm sorry I'm not sure I understand
we're talking about your suggestions
that you don't ask
that your force is institutionally
racist
I absolutely accept the diagnosis that
Louise Casey comes up with we have
racist misogynist and homophobes in the
organization and it's not just about
individuals we have systemic failings
management failings and cultural
failings the reason and I respect Louise
using that term the reason I don't use
it um I think it's a very ambiguous term
your your viewers would have different
interpretations what it means
well let's bring in our home and it's
Jason Farrell for more on this so Jason
good to have you with us this evening
now uh Dame Louise Casey described her
Mark rowley's task as climbing Mount
Everest in flip-flops will you get there
well I think everyone accepts is going
to take time even the Home Secretary
Suella bravaman saying this will take
years and indeed Louise Louise Casey
says this isn't going to happen
overnight there is a big problem here
and it's going to take a while to root
out those people who are causing that
problem she accepts that many officers
who work within the police the majority
of them are very professional they don't
have this problem but that doesn't
change the fact that it is an
Institutional problem in her view
because it seeps right through the force
and it's affecting it when we talk about
sexism it's not just the officers in the
force who who actually experience that
sexism but it kind of feeds into the
investigations as well and she says
symbolic of that is for example these
fridges that have been used to store
evidence where they are broken or
dilapidated or stuffed full of
rape kits and then so so much that they
can't close the door and in one instance
in in the summer when we have that heat
wave they actually lost samples and that
meant that rape cases couldn't go
forward and I think anyone who's ever
had experienced sexual assault will be
outraged even if they haven't by that
fact that rape cases were ruined because
evidence was ruined because it wasn't
kept properly and lose Casey sees that
as symbolic of the problem and it is it
is symbolic because in a sense the door
is broken on the Metropolitan Police
because it has become contaminated by
misogynistic Behavior by racism and by
homophobia so it is going to take it is
going to take time to go through all of
those cases that the Met says they're
going through now looking back into the
history of police officers to see if
they have for example histories of
domestic violence but I think the big
question is you know where do you draw
the line what is the Line in the Sand on
behavior from the past that means you
can't keep your job in Louis in Louise
Casey's view she was very clear with me
she said anything like that and they
should be sacked
okay Jason for now do appreciate that
thank you now you have been submitting
your questions uh to us all afternoon
and I'm joined Now by Palm Sandy who's
the first Asian female Chief
superintendent in that he met her Memoir
on her time in the police force is
called black and blue one woman's story
of policing and Prejudice and also here
is Michael Fuller former Chief Constable
of Kent Police and a former met
commander who is also who was also sorry
the Chief Inspector of the crown
prosecution service Palm Michael really
good to have you both with us um this
evening let's just get straight into the
questions that we've had come in from
our viewers and this one is coming from
Wilson you can see it there in the
screen I'll read out to you Pam if you
can start with this what's new in this
Casey report that the public didn't
already know about the Met since the
McPherson inquiry some 25 years ago I
think that's a really good question
because the answer is nothing
the the Met was labeled as
institutionally racist then 25 almost 25
years ago and it's still carrying that
label and in fact it's been expanded to
include homophobia and misogyny so that
question
um it's not one to say yes there's
something new in there but we're going
round in circles and the Met seems to
have gone backwards in that there were
some recommendations made and they were
very positive and they were taken on but
over the last few years that has been
eroded and the Met has actually gone
backwards Michael would you agree that
it's gone backwards as lessons been
learned I think some of the issues is
still there that at the end of the day
the label institutional racism
um has been said before 25 years ago by
William McPherson
um I think I think what matters now is
is what do we do you know how do we fix
the problems what's the plan and that's
the thing the the chief officers in the
meds need to answer I mean these are the
questions that rest at the time of the
week the report they weren't they
institutionally racist was the term I
remember it very well so those questions
will have been asked it's not like
they're they're new questions right well
there are some things that have happened
and of course as you know I've written
about it but
um at the end of the day at the time and
I was in The Meta at the time and I
spent 26 years in the meds the racial
discrimination was not a disciplinary
offense and post McPherson that that was
changed
um at the end of the day the notion of
hate crime
um wasn't in existence and that that was
changed
um at the end of the day murder
investigations are reviewed the issue of
Double Jeopardy and that um people being
able to be prosecuted again if there was
new evidence that came to light was as a
result of the McPherson report and of
course it meant that the the some of the
people involved in the killing of
Stephen Lawrence were were actually and
have been convicted in a way that's pre
the MacPherson report they would not
have being convicted how much of that
would you agree with Paul I mean there's
some fundamental changes there laid out
by Michael and I do agree with
everything that Michael said but one
thing I would would say is that I at
time there was an argument about the
label institutional racism that argument
is still carrying on and I listen to Sir
Mark absolutely I listened to him this
morning and he's still arguing about the
term institutional and he's arguing it's
systematic it's he's used all sorts of
other terminology well the time for
arguments about terminology have long
gone and now as Michael has said it's a
Time for Action people are tired of the
reports that say the same thing there
are things fundamentally wrong with the
Met do something about it just a thought
on that because you've brought it up and
Mark Rally's sort of reluctance to talk
to use the word institutionally why do
you think he found it so difficult to do
though when he said he didn't want to
use it right it's not what I told me he
would you would use I think because it
means that everyone is labeled I I had
offices at the time say well I've got a
black wife I'm white but I got a black
wife how can I be racist and you know
I'm affected by this label
institutionally racist but at the end of
the day you're looking at issues that
are systemic in the way that say black
people as are treated in terms of stop
and search in terms of black and Asian
officers in fact the fact they face are
more likely to face as Louise Casey has
pointed out they're more likely to face
disciplinary action so there are those
issues that are systemic and run through
the whole system and and a lot of the
things that were pointed out 25 years
ago have still not
um still not been changed they had they
haven't been addressed successfully and
that's why I don't think the Mets should
be in denial it should be looking
forward you know how are we going to
change how we're going to provide an
effective and a service to to all of
London uh and and and uh service that um
that doesn't discriminate yeah I've got
there's more questions but let's go to
our viewers questions because they've
got better ones than me I think this is
William North now which asks the
question that um I think many people are
wondering after what we've seen uh come
out of Louise Casey's report today why
isn't the force uh broken up with
immediate effects and set up a new
police force with a new name new staff
and remove as William no says all the
bad apples
that's a difficult fun to do but there
have been recommendations made about
certain units being disbanded
immediately and that's including the
Firearms units that do the Parliamentary
protection and diplomatic protection
which is where Carrick and Casey were
both based so those recommendations have
been made in Louise Casey's report today
now whether or not they're going to be
acted on that's a different matter
because I haven't heard anything coming
from the Met to say that that is
actually going to be actioned and in
relation to the bigger subject about
reform I think that Sir Mark has been
given the last chance people want to see
the turnaround plan but not two years
from now they want to see that
turnaround plan being implemented now
and there are solutions but if you don't
admit you've got a problem you're not
going to find those Solutions no I mean
I I guess you would agree with much of
that that it's not the thing to do at
this moment I I think it'd be a
distraction actually I've been involved
in lots of restructurings of the meds
and at the end of the day what I feel
matters more is a is about leadership
that you have proper leadership and
supervision of the staff at the end of
the day when cousins that you know the
nickname the rapist well who knew that
and who did something about it you know
if you've got supervisors other
colleagues of that officer
um suspecting that somebody is a rapist
you know what did they do about it and
there must be some culpability amongst
people who knew that somebody was a bad
apple and didn't do anything about it I
mean you've touched on some one of the
things that really occurred to me today
I mean you guys have both worked in the
force for a long period of period of
time when you know things like that why
aren't those things rooted out
well yeah I think the Mets should be
asked that because that's what they've
got to do to to change things to the
better you know just the matter who had
these problems is it no it isn't just
the met but I think at the end of the
day we we want an effective Police
Service we we want protection and
um we want protection that gives
protection to women and girls
um people who might be vulnerable in
some way that we want protection for for
all and a service that serves everybody
in in London and and does that in a fair
way that's something I did I felt
successfully in Kent and I didn't
tolerate any discrimination any any
misogyny we had 30 percent more women
selected whilst I was there because we
took out discriminatory processes from
the selection promotion selection
systems and I think the zero tolerance
approach and and Leadership by by those
and we're not talking about people are
just at the top it's people at the
bottom of the supervision ladder who
have far more influence on the culture
of the organization did you see some of
that culture I was just about to say I
can tell you why people don't um stand
up because if they do stand up and they
call out bad behavior of their
colleagues the chances of that being
investigated are very slim I think it's
seven out of 10 cases are not proceeded
with and the person who is brave enough
to stand tall is then alienated
victimized demonized and they become
subjective complaints malicious
complaints themselves that's why there's
no safe environment for people to
whistle blow I think the question is
there are structures in place to protect
whistleblowers there are structures but
they are not they they seem to protect
the the protagonists more and that's
actually in Louise Casey's report she's
actually commented on the fact that the
people who actually raise the complaints
the burden for them is too heavy to bear
and it becomes a protection system for
the person who's in the wrong in the
first place maybe that's a way that it
could be turned around quite quickly it
would seem Michael I I I would agree
with that and but I say that's wrong the
if you see something wrong and you
report it you shouldn't be seen as the
problem no if you face discrimination
you face bullying you shouldn't then be
seen as a problem so it says there must
be protections for people who raise
legitimate grievances or even if they're
considered not legitimate they they
there should be protections for people
with freedom for people to raise those
complaints that goes back to the overall
culture though of political Services
let's move on to uh the question now
from Tess if we can
um and this is uh maybe a bit of a
controversial one here I want you guys
to give us your opinion on this it says
it's been argued that police are
academically uneducated and if it would
be mandatory they had a degree to join
the police force would that improve the
system Tom one of the best things that's
happened recently is the fact that
people who are joining now are being put
onto a degree program so that um that
comment there would no longer apply and
the new recruits are part of the
positive change for the future because
they are diluting that toxic culture
they are changing it they won't tolerate
it and by getting rid of that old God
and those old attitudes that's how you
will actually change the met so in
relation to that question new officers
will be getting a degree at the end of
their probationary period and if they
don't study or they don't achieve that
status or they do something wrong they
can be removed from their positions
quite quickly it's easy to get rid of a
probationer and it's very difficult to
get rid of somebody who's got more
service yeah and Michael I mean I bet
you're an advocate of lifelong and you
become a KC during your time no no no
qpm but at the end of the day yes I've
got four degrees but I mean that that
doesn't make you a good leader
um so
um I can remember Kent that um all my
management team had master's degrees but
at the end of the day that doesn't make
you a good leader that training people
in leadership and effective supervision
are the most important things and you
have people who are very competent and
professional at their job and I had a
good experience last Saturday in London
where I called out police to a rave in a
park in a legal Rave and all the
officers who didn't know who I was I was
very scruffily dressed
um we're very polite and respectful for
me dealt with the issue and I thank them
afterwards and I thought gosh you know
if only the Met were like that all the
time
um I applied professional responsive
which they haven't always been that um
everybody would be pleased and they
didn't make I didn't feel any judgment
about what I look like that is good that
you weren't judged on the way you
address Michael let's move on to the
next question that we have on here and
this is um this is about the met and
policing broadly nationally it says the
Mets the model for UK policing where
does this leave us nationally especially
as smaller forces have less oversight I
mean you from police I think the Met
tries to do too much to be honest it has
National responsibilities and I think
personally the focus should be on
policing London and the problems in
London is London is a complex City to
police and then the Met does things well
it does them really well we saw with the
Queen's funeral
um you know we we've seen with lots of
other public events and response to
terrorism the Met has responded very
well and professionally
um but you know when it gets things
wrong it's disastrous and it's very
complex to sort out because of the size
of it so yeah just just focus on London
and London's problems but restructuring
is is a huge undertaking and that's not
something I would want to do I've been
through three and it's a distraction
from some of these issues that we're
talking about we need to focus on fixing
these problems um I think implied in
that question as well as the Met is
looked up to by other forces around the
country is that the experience of do
other police officers in different parts
of the country look towards the Met
places as being the Pinnacle of policing
what I would say is that there are
police officers up and down the country
including in the Met who work incredibly
hard and they do very very difficult
jobs the majority of them are good
hard-working individuals now I don't
think that there is a hierarchy in that
somebody's better than anybody else or a
force is better but because the Met have
got more resources they've got more
opportunities to diversify into
different departments it may be seen as
a you know having more opportunities but
I don't think it's seen as being better
than any other force one of the things
that came up earlier today was the idea
of taking parts of of the force away we
talked about counterterrorism as well
and maybe we've been pulled into the
National Crime agency you've seen that
as being a viable way do you think of
taking some of that pressure off the
invention I still think that's a
distraction I mean you've got the
culture that existed within the
protection
group and amongst those officers was
clearly wrong and and you know what what
is being done to change that culture
change some of those people what was
that about is that because they were
carrying guns they were seen as sort of
elite officers you're nodding your head
yes kind of thing there is there is a
sort of hierarchy within policing and if
you've there's there's a huge amount of
training to become a Firearms officer so
it is seen as being part of an elite
unit and also they get more money spent
on them because they're buying the guns
they're buying the body armor they're
buying all the latest kit and when you
go to Frontline officers the ones who
come out to the 999 course or the
illegal raves in the park they don't
have as much money or resources they are
working on very tight budgets and shift
work so yes there is a hierarchy in
different units and different
departments and unfortunately those
other departments are that are very
insular they think that they're better
than everybody else they don't mingle
they don't talk to other people and
brand new recruits go to the front line
which is why the culture will change
brand new recruits will not end up in a
Firearms unit which is why I do support
what Louise Casey has said about
disbanding those units yeah the only
thing I'd say is that I commanded
operation Trident which was dealing with
gun crime in London Over a four-year
period and um each year I'd command up
to about 75 armed operations and I would
say because it would have been in the
news that all those operations that we
dealt with throughout the year we've
always carried out very professionally
and with meticulous planning because
there have been mistakes you'd have
heard about them I mean there are
mistakes as we know we've seen with John
Charlton menezes and recently as well
but that wasn't part of the operation
yes you know if you have human beings
actually involved in these things but
the point is that Over a four-year
period of the operations I commanded
there weren't mistakes and the
operations were conducted very
professionally by the Firearms officers
the only other criticism as well of
those elite units as we've been
describing is they can be kind of close
shops as well so when there is any
attempt at whistleblowing it's all part
of an elite club and people feel less
inclined to blow the whistle on their
mates and I think that is that is that
is a real problem but then you get back
to what I said at the start is you need
people who who are good leaders and
effective leaders and supervisors of
those people and and I think also that
they they need to be accountable so if
if there's an issue with an officer
under their command what I always found
was that I I was also subject of
complaints and I was as accountable as
as the officer who was Junior and I I
think that that's that was very
important but it made sure that I had
very tight control over what people did
under my command since recount it's
vital part Michael we'll leave it there
for a moment we're going to move on uh
to take a look at the uh the victims of
uh these incidents of uh police for all
the talk of institutional fail into
reality for police failure for many is a
legacy of loss trauma and fearernag has
yes
in 2020 Faye says she was assaulted by a
stranger on her way home an event that
left her traumatized and feeling the
Metropolitan Police did not take her
seriously I felt
belittled and dismissed over the phone I
didn't
feel that it was taken seriously the
fact that
I wasn't assured that
this might not happen to someone else
that the Met couldn't dispatch somebody
to patrol the area just made me have
really little faith in how much they
value women's safety or Public Safety
the forces review of phase account
deemed the service they provided was
acceptable but said that several points
of learning were identified the report
added I apologize on behalf of the
Metropolitan Police that you felt it
necessary to complain
zarelina was minutes from her front door
when in June last year she was attacked
and killed by a man who was on license
and had just been released from prison
Jordan McSweeney had followed several
women that night but the alarm was never
raised Zara's Aunt blames this on a lack
of trust between the community and the
Met why didn't those women call the
police is it because they don't think
they're going to be taken seriously is
it because they're so scared of what
officers have done to women themselves
trust that's particularly hard to find
in some communities June and Shola have
been working with marginalized people
and the Metropolitan Police for decades
they praised some of the officers
they've worked with but this review
confirms what they suspected of The
Wider Force as a black male
I've been stopped by the police
so many times I can't even tell you how
many times if we keep waiting on report
after report to get this right how many
more lives are we going to lose or
effect
or have traumatized young people coming
up
a retired DCI from the Met who worked on
the Wayne cousins investigation says
keeping existing officers will be
difficult the majority of people are
hard working that now that retention of
those officers
has got to be part of this as well to
keep the good ones there to change
things for good because they're going to
feel like this is a personal attack on
them
to avoid an incident like this all sides
agree change is needed this review was
commissioned because these women were
failed baroness Casey's findings show
Britain's largest police force is
continuing to fail large parts of
Britain's Capital
Sky News
well actually this report just really
lays out the sort of the difficulties
facing in policing and uh trying to help
victims of crime and this next question
here that's coming from an anonymous
viewer
um really sort of lays that out
um I'll read it out for how can I know
when I'm walking home from the train
station after work that will happen to
Sarah everard when it happened to me how
can women in the UK trust the law and
the officers that supposedly carry out
their Duty as sworn protectors when the
Met failed Sarah I mean it's a really
emotive question it's a huge question to
ask but it's really the fear that many
people have at a time like this have to
a report that's so damaging and I think
that the question itself is is one that
can cannot be answered because trust and
confidence in policing is well below the
50 in in the London area and it's fallen
and it's dramatically fallen and until
that conflict trust and confidence is
restored then policing by consent is at
risk and that is a horrible thing to say
and even when you look the Wayne cousins
and the Carrick and the other people
that have come for that have come to
notice
I'm not sure that there isn't another
one somewhere along the way there could
be another one of those individuals
within the met but what I would say is
that if there is anybody at home that
needs help
um and that is immediate in immediate
danger they should pick up the phone and
they should ask for that help and it's
really important that we get that
message over because otherwise we are
going to lose people we are going to
have people who are being beaten who are
suffering and who could possibly be
killed by other people but in relation
to trusting the police that's something
that's going to come back in time and in
time but how long will that take well I
think it will take a long time but at
the end of the day I mean I know that
trust is lacking I had um
um a few few weeks ago a woman who is on
my doorstep looked the worse for drink
about two or three in the morning I
thought it was my daughter it wasn't and
she said she was just using it as a my
doorstep as a safe Refuge
um because it had a bright street light
and it made me feel the the streets
don't look look very safe because they
are very dark with austerity and is is
not just the police who need to increase
safety and confidence of people the
issue of public protection I think
concerns local authorities as well
um and I think we've we've forgotten
there's this issue of the fact that we
it's important that the public are
properly protected that yeah the police
are there to catch criminals but they're
also there to protect the public and and
everybody and and this woman didn't feel
safe because I said well she was under
threat from her boyfriend I offered to
call the police and she said no no no
you didn't want to come he didn't want
the police being called which made you
know it's quite a shock for me
um but anyway she she was safe and there
was a happy ending well that's good too
but it's it's so concerning that she
would not want to get the police
involved in innocent when she doesn't
feel safe yeah and it brings home the
fact that there is a an extreme lack of
confidence in in policing at the moment
people have got to feel safe and of
course the vast majority of officers and
that's important the vast majority of
officers are very professional and in
the way they respond and in the way they
behave so um you know people can't feel
um afraid of of actually dialing the 999
if they are under threat and in a state
of emergency in some way in that um they
they need to call the police they've got
to feel confident about doing that but
reports like this just don't help that
at all do they know let's move on to the
next question here and this is about
smart Corrales I'm not sure how much you
guys are going to want to comment on
this but I'll put it to you anyway uh
how many years did the current
commissioner serve in the Met Senior
Management before being appointed to his
current role and how did he not notice
what was going on why didn't he speak
out and why should he be the man to make
change now Palmer going to put that to
you first and you saw me smiling I did I
think that perhaps that question would
be best suited for Mark Rowley himself I
mean Kate tried to put some of that to
him this morning and he and he didn't
really both everyone has given him his
their support both sides of the
political divide of giving them his
supports the mayor of London has given
them his support to try and make change
yes I know that he was there in 2018
because I left in 2019 and I'm at a loss
to answer the question as to why didn't
he see because he was in charge of the
Firearms units he was in charge of the
Wayne cousins and the Derek the Carrick
case so how did he not notice and I I
did see his response this morning that
he was too busy fighting Isis well
you're fighting Isis and you don't see
what's happening under your nose and are
women of this country less important
that's the question I'd be asking
I think I think what I'd say and it's
not sidestepping the issue is that he's
now got a chance to change things for
the better but why should he get that
chance when he was there before he was
in the met from the inside he knows how
it works one of the biggest problems
that independent people I've found who
come from other police forces have had
in the met and I've served in the 26
years under lots of different leaders is
that those who from outside London it
takes them a long time to get to know
the city the complexities of policing a
big complex Capital so he hasn't got
that too you know at the end of the day
he's got some serious issues that he's
got a chance to address and he's going
to be judged by that as to how effective
he is addressing and leading the people
under his charge but but with that
with there being so many concerns about
the way that the force is working and
with people's lives literally being on
the line about this should he be given
that chance to do that I mean just as a
thought experiment if he was to be
removing someone to be was to replace
him would that be the sort of Clean
Sweep the New Broom that you you need do
you think well he is a noob room and uh
he's a new commissioner and he's got the
chance to do something about
um whilst he might be allowed to have
the opportunity to change the map I
don't think he is a new broom and I do
disagree a little bit with you Michael
there because when we talk about
independence that doesn't mean that you
bring somebody in from outside London if
that's not what you want to do it
doesn't mean that somebody who has been
in London has got the the Magic Touch to
make those problems go away and having
an independent person sometimes it
shines the torch where you may not be
looking because Louise Casey is
independent all of the evidence that
she's produced was part of the Met
evidence it's part of met data and yet
the people who were within the Met
didn't see it didn't notice it didn't
think it was a problem and it took an
independent person so in my view that
he's not a new broom he was there before
he's gone back how is that independent
how is that a new brim okay he's new at
a commissioner but he was an assistant
commissioner before so I do disagree
with you let me push on that then so
where should the person to lead the
organization like the metropolitan
police come from then if not from
someone who who knows the force and
knows the city as as Michael lays out
well I I'm not sure I can answer that
but I can say that it needs to be
somebody independent as does the
complaints procedures because at the
moment you've got police officers who
are managing the complaints department
who the week before could have been
working with a Wayne cousins or a
Carrick and now they're investigating
those same people they may have been
complicit they may have been laughing at
the jokes they may have been calling him
the rapist in an endearing manner so
those are the people who investigate
complaints that's not Independence and
that's why those complaints just go
around and round and there's nothing to
come of them I mean there's something
really fundamental at the base of this
I've been racking my brains to work out
where the real change needs to be made
and if you don't think you think it's at
the top you don't think it's at the top
you know please invite consent is
something that we all live by we still
disagree with that I think it does need
to be at the top but it needs to be all
throughout the organization so it wasn't
just the the people at the top who were
calling it wasn't the people that top
they were calling when cousins the
rapists you know there were people who
work very closely with him who would
have known or suspected about his
activities and what did they do about it
you know I don't know but I mean the
point being not enough it is about the
leadership of the organization and I
think the acid test is how good a leader
um that that person at the top is but
also those people all throughout the
organization who have the opportunity to
to influence an effect and identify the
bad apples yeah and and they're few and
far between but there will be people who
will know the of the bad apples and
they've got to have Safe Systems of
reporting and be able to report them so
that they they're tackled and they're
they're kicked out I mean my policy in
Kent so I'm not just saying this
academically was if I had officers who I
felt were a risk because of
indiscretions in terms of allegations
that were made in terms of sexual
indiscretions
um they were dismissed and I was happy
with that and the rest of the force were
happy with that and more important the
public were happy with that so I don't
think anyone was unfairly treated they
were all given due process but the point
is I would not take the risk of keeping
them within the organization I don't
think the Mets should do that either I
mean how do you think police officers
have been feeling to have seen a few of
them out around the streets today of
course keeping us all as safe as they
can how do you think like serving
officers would be feeling right now I
think that the majority of officers who
are good and caring individuals will be
absolutely distraught at this report
distraught at the labels that are have
been offered out but at the same time
they're also angry because police
officers who aren't shouldn't be in the
force have been allowed to linger and
stay there there's some case studies
that Louise has used where officers have
been in the force up to two years after
allegations of sexual misconduct have
come to light they've racked up another
11 or 12 complaints against them that
are known and there may be others that
would that have not complained so those
people have stayed within the force so
the good and caring officers are
frustrated that even when they raise
their head and they say I'm working with
the rapist that allegation isn't going
to go anywhere it's not that doesn't
mean that that person is going to be
removed do you think that Casey's
Baron's Casey's report will give
confidence to those officers the good
officers who may see uh wrongdoing
happening and feel like they couldn't
report it before but perhaps after this
they they could well please do nothing
there to give them that sense of
confidence well the report highlights of
that clearly the disciplinary processes
haven't worked in the officers who
should have been
um really kicked out of the police
haven't been and that the vetting
processes haven't worked and and those
are the issues I feel the people at the
top have got a chance to to put and
we're talking the sort of the political
people in in governments over the police
you can can actually change the sort of
current restrictions that prevented the
officers actually being removed from the
policing because we we want police
officers who are honest who we can trust
who we respect who are ethical and
professional in the way they behave and
and clearly you know the the current
disciplinary regulations in the way
they've they've operated haven't haven't
allowed that to happen yeah plenty of
work still to be done I've had a few
messages from serving officers today
because I'm still a mentor and so one of
them was this report is 10 years too
late another one was about time and
thank God she called it out for what it
is so that's the general opinion of the
serving officers and you know there are
a lot of them that are really
disillusioned because of what's been
allowed to happen over the last few
years to come forward after this yeah
and one of the things is we've seen a
lot of reports but what matters to me is
what you're going to do to fix it yeah
so I think you know the the focus needs
to be on not police bashing but actually
fixing the problems that are being
identified yeah and that that's what's
going to be most important not to not
for it to be a political football
because that never gets us anywhere and
I've seen that over a 25-year period
well let's hope that in a few years time
we're not sitting around having the same
similar discussion about a major police
force in the UK Palmerston doing Michael
I really appreciate it I'm really
enlightening great discussion thank you
very much both of you this evening